peut déjà annoncer c'est une large
victoire de renaud muselier en provence
alpes côte d'azur avec aux alentours de
55% on aura les résultats dans un peu
plus ben voila vous les avez 56%
donc selon ifop fiducial dans les hauts
de france c'est la victoire comme
attendu de xavier bertrand qui voit là
on va le voir arriver dépasse donc les
50 % 51 9% devant la liste du
rassemblement national de sébastien
chenu avec 26 5% et karima delli qui
améliore son score du premier tour 21 6
% en région au now verne rhône alpes
laurent wauquiez transforme sans
surprise le laisser du premier tour avec
54 6% devant la liste de gauche et d
écologie écologistes 33 5 % et loin
devant le rassemblement national qui
fait un score inférieur à celui du
premier tour avec 11 9%
on a également les résultats en
bourgogne franche comté où la socialiste
sortante marie-guite dufay est déclaré
vainqueur on a également les résultats
en occitanie ou carole delga améliore
son score de 2 min 2015 avec plus de 50%
également en nouvelles aquitaine ou à la
rousset arrive nettement en tête et donc
est déclaré vainqueur avec vous voyez
39% devant la liste du rassemblement
national et nicolas hasle nicolas
florian des républicains qui fait jeu
égal avec les écologistes et qui passe
devant la liste menée par la ministre
modène geneviève darrieussecq et enfin
en bretagne c'est le sortant loïg
chesnais girard qui est déclaré
vainqueur avec aux alentours de 30%